oh you know that music means it's time
for Tucker's final exam where the news
professionals are interrogated see if
they can actually remember the events
they cover every day this week's final
exam is a New York special we have
Kennedy the last non guest host in the
building and also with us from Fox News
headlights 24/7 Carly Shimkus
and actually speaking a guest hosting
Carly will actually be in this slot on
Monday night but for some reason we're
gonna stick her outside for the duration
of the show and then Kennedy will follow
Carly so this is the Fox New Year's Eve
team you'll you'll get a heads up on
ahead worth tuning in ok contestants
hands on buzzers I'm gonna ask the
questions and the first one to buzz in
gets to answer but you must wait until I
finish asking you can answer once and I
shall acknowledge you according to rules
set by the International quiz show
committee in Geneva by saying your name
correct answer is worth one point get it
wrong you lose a point best of five wins
let's get started question one an
outgoing Democrat senator just blasted
newcomer Alexandria Ocasio Cortes
calling her a shiny new object with
cheap rhetoric which lawmaker made those
remarks and it's Kennedy Claire
McCaskill Claire McCaskill let's roll
that tape I don't know her I'm a little
confused why she's the thing but it's a
good example what I'm talking about a
bright and shiny new object the
rhetorics cheap getting results is a lot
harder milk
where the Lord split chest so that's
first blood to Kennedy one-zip as we
head into question two this is critical
for Carly otherwise she'll be losing
that New Year's Eve gig question
question two former First Lady Michelle
Obama is now the most admired woman in
all of America that's according to a new
Gallup poll but to get there Michelle
Obama had to bump another woman who'd
held on to the top spot for 17 years
who was the other and it's Kennedy just
a guest for me anyway Hillary Clinton oh
come on
Hillary Clinton the most admired woman
in America ever 70 are you kidding me
let's roll that tape Michelle Obama has
overtaken Hillary Clinton as the most
admired woman in the country you get in
Clinton held that top spot on that list
for 17 years what does that say about
Hillary now I wanted to say Oprah I
thought I feel like that truly is one of
the most admired women in America but I
think Hillary is now third Oprah is
number two but it's a tragedy for
Hillary she was once the most admired
woman in America I blame the latvian bot
farm and misogyny yeah you know there
are other women on the list still very
misogynistic that she got the heave-ho
yeah absolutely
clearly on that list as well four and
five yeah Macedonian content farmers
it's one point come on you don't want to
be outside on New Year's Eve this is
they will give you did in your studio if
you can turn this question three we
recently told you about a popular
calendar in Russia which features
various images of a shirtless Vladimir
Putin that same calendar is now a
monster hit in another country and is
outselling ones featuring puny homegrown
celebrities which country is it
[Music]
this is humanity the United States chess
less Putin in the United States
let's see doesn't sound likely I'm
blushing they're flying off the shelves
in Japan feature dipping into a hot tub
and posing with a fish sixty years old
he's not looking too bad here he is
cuddling a leopard a very docile leopard
the popularity of calendars is
reportedly fueled by a surge and
self-proclaimed Putin fans get them
while they're hot ladies lady likes
being in a hot tub with a KGB torturer
candidate disastrous move there she's
lost one point right so there's still
everything to play for it's 2-0 question
four what's a bulge or zero you're in
huge trouble man question four this is a
multiple choice question there's a
crisis on the International Space
Station something mysterious was found
by astronauts inside a capsule that
recently docked there and Russian
officials say it's the result of a major
breach what was it they found a sharp
knife be a tiny hole or see a jar of
pickles and it's the trigger-happy
Kennedy yet again what do you say Joe
pickles a matter of life and death a
tiny hole discovered an abortion capsule
the docks to the International Space
Station at first scientists suspected
the hole was caused by a meteorite
strike and a good unobstructed view now
of that black spot that's the hole on
the external hole a Russian cosmonaut
who examined the hole believes it was
drilled from inside the capsule
on the show if you're a Russian
cosmonaut just plug that hole with the
picture of Vladimir Putin chest 'less in
the whole battle battle take care of it
okay so as a result Kennedy's lost
another point it's now zero zero game in
the history of this show
final question we've been dipping into
the New Year champagne too much Wasel
and figgy pudding final question another
multiple choice listen carefully there
is a viral video of a Colorado woman
chasing down a thief who had stolen her
Christmas packages from her front door
now there's a special name given to
people who steal in this way is it a a
porch pirate be a parcel poacher or see
a package for this car succeeded
actually they win I do not know okay
let's let's see I'm going with a porch
pirate porch pirate roll tape the
scourge of the holiday season those
pesky porch pirates intent on ruining
Christmas but one woman in liquid
Colorado has decided to take matters
into her own hands I looked at my ring
videos and I saw what happened Renea
betta confronting the brazen pirate who
made her way through the neighborhood
with her stolen booty I thought no way
is this happening to me
[Music]
and I would have ran for as many miles
as I had to to get my package for her
yeah Keira Knightley didn't talk like
that and ports Pirates of the Caribbean
that is said now we have an amazing this
is a humiliation for this I don't
deserve it not election victory was a
sure mark Kennedy did all the heavy
lifting and I should say popular vote no
your hand that's hitting that buzzer
Carly just hit it hits it once and takes
the trophy can I say thank you so much I
believe that Moke really should go to
Kennedy no I can't stand this good
sportsmanship
there is your Tucker Carlson mouth
breather bug you will see these ladies
in this time on Monday that's all for
this week's final exam pay attention to
the news each week and tune in on
Thursdays to see if you can do better
than one bus Carly